Киянину Василю - 28, він називає себе успішним підприємцем і патріотом.
Я поміж речей, котрі виробляються не в Україні і в Україні при "прочіх равних"
стараюсь вибирати саме українські. Це одна з моїх… патріотичних речей.
За таким принципом ще торік хлопець придбав собі гвинтівку.
Зброя - на американській системі AR-15, але зібрана в Україні.
Для захисту себе, для захисту країни, якщо буде потреба.
Я є членом ТРО - це територіальна оборона України. І в нас є момент,
який, мені здається, не так давно був виправлений, але я не впевнений.
Проблема була в тому, що наша зброя зберігалася в "Десні" і вона має бути в нас
тільки через 48 годин після тривоги. І тому у вас є 48 годин зробити,
що хочеш з 300 патріотами України, які там проводили дуже серйозні навчання.
Тому я прийняв рішення, що я не хочу передавати своє життя якійсь бюрократії.
Я краще буду мати при собі таку зброю, буду тренуватися, можу на полювання ходити,
якщо дуже захочу... Напевне, ніколи не захочу.
Василь на вихідних відвідує тренування свого батальйону тероборони,
а щосереди тренується в тирі. Хоча родичі й знайомі не завжди розуміють
таке захоплення молодого бізнесмена.
По-перше, мені це подобається. По-друге, ситуація до цього спонукає.
По-третє, я є патріотом, я вважаю - а що тут такого? А в чому різниця,
чи це будуть росіяни, чи це буде Янукович офігевший, який думає що в нього є "Беркут"
і він може щось зробити. А ви можете зараз уявити, що хтось може стріляти по Майдану?
Я не дуже можу. У людей карабіни…
Скільки зброї на руках в українців - порахувати складно.
Адже за даними Офісу генпрокурора, кількість нелегальних "стволів"
може сягати від трьох до п'яти мільйонів.
За офіційної кількості близько мільйона двохсот тисяч одиниць зареєстрованої законної зброї.
Це дані за жовтень 2021-го. Але вони не надто змінювалися протягом останніх кількох років.
Та нині продавці зброї відзначають зростання попиту.
За останній місяць ми помітили збільшення попиту десь на 10-15 відсотків.
Нам важко це сказати одразу, бо в нашій країні отримати дозвіл на зброю
це не питання одного тижня.
Загроза нового російського вторгнення дещо підігріла попит на зброю,
визнають у цій крамниці. Оцінюють рівень занепокоєння насамперед за продажами боєприпасів.
Наш народ, він дуже запасливий. І всі розумують, що якщо щось трапиться,
не дай Бог звичайно, ніхто цього не бажає, але якщо щось трапиться,
то змоги прийти в магазин купити набої просто ні в кого не буде.
А стрільці - вони запасливі в квадраті. Тому у будь-якого стрільця
має бути так званий БК, тобто десь 200-300 набоїв має бути, плюс тренування.
Тому по набоям десь відсотків на 20-25 зріс попит.
Уся зброя в крамницях - мисливська або спортивна, адже лише така дозволена в Україні.
Новоспечені власники дозволів на зброю найбільше цікавляться
гладкоствольними помповими рушницями. Ціни на них стартують від 6-7 тисяч гривень.
На другому місці за популярністю автомати Калашникова.
Йдеться про їхню цивільну версію - "калаші", які стріляють не чергою, а одиничними пострілами.
Тільки такі може придбати звичайний громадянин.
Викласти доведеться приблизно 25-30 тисяч гривень.
Купують і американські карабіни AR-15. Вони дорожчі - від 35 тисяч гривень.
Ціни на всі товари зросли разом з курсом долара.
Люди дуже бояться мародерства. Вони бояться, що якщо почнуться якісь бойові дії,
то злочинці скористаються цим, і почнеться грабування домівок, автівок і так далі.
І потрібно щось мати в першу чергу для захисту домівки.
І тому в даному випадку частіше за все беруть саме помпові рушниці 12-го калібру.
Чому вони найпростіші? Тому що вам треба буде навчитися лише одному руху
- ось цьому: клац-клац.
Ще в одній зброярні згадують початок війни на Сході.
У 2014-ому, за їхніми словами, гвинтівки розбирали за передзамовленнями ще з заводу.
Нині ажіотажу немає, але в тирі при крамниці відвідувачів побільшало
- люди хочуть навчатися стрільбі.
Якщо є у людини зброя, то нею треба вміти користуватися.
Це як мати машину, але не вміти їздити. Або не ходити в школу
і не навчатися. Це досить небезпечно.
Інструктори зі стрільби, з якими поспілкувалася DW, наполягають:
багато зброї на руках у цивільних - не завжди добре, а то й небезпечно.
Якщо люди не тренуються регулярно, вони можуть ненароком
нашкодити собі та оточуючим. До того ж розраховувати на повноцінний захист
у разі війни з дозволеною в Україні зброєю не доводиться.
У разі військової агресії ми боїмося не так військових, як зростання злочинності,
що будуть мародери, буде більше неконтрольованих угруповань,
і саме від них треба захищатися такою зброєю.
Від військових у бронежилетах і касках такою зброєю захищатися…
Навіть якщо вона є, рівні підготовки у цивільного й військового все ж таки відрізняються.
На думку полковника в запасі й військового експерта Олега Жданова,
у разі бойових дій вміння цивільного населення користуватися зброєю
- вагома перевага. Насамперед за умови організованого спротиву.
Це, наприклад, та ж територіальна оборона.
Навченість цивільного населення дає перевагу навіть в підготовці самої оборони,
тому що жодна війна ще не обійшлася без добровольчих формувань. Жодна.
Територіальна оборона не буде застосовуватися і не повинна застосовуватися там,
де працює важка артилерія. Там застосовуються Збройні сили, і для того вони і є.
Територіальна оборона застосовується на місцевості і, я вам скажу,
ефективність від неї навіть більша, ніж від Збройних сил,
тому що Збройні сили діють в прямому протистоянні.
Тобто вони ведуть контактний бій. Тероборона призначена для ведення засідок
і нападу зненацька. А цей фактор нападу зненацька завжди дає перевагу.
Коли стріляє кожен дім, взяти місто… дуже важко.
Нині загрозу російського вторгнення вже не називають невідворотною.
Таке заявляють і українські, й американські посадовці.
Утім для резервіста тероборони Василя це не привід ховати гвинтівку до сейфу.
На його думку, бойова підготовка ніколи зайвою не буде.
Це наша нова реальність, ми отак будемо жити. Ізраїль так живе 80 років.
Південна Корея з 46-го року так живе. Ми повинні розуміти, що ми на передньому краї оборони,
і що якщо ти не хочеш своєю безпекою займатися - ну, сорян.
Секретар РНБО Олексій Данілов в інтерв'ю Associated Press заявив,
що Україна може мобілізувати до двох з половиною мільйонів людей
у разі вторгнення Росії. При цьому Данілов нагадав і про мільйон українців,
які мають мисливські ліцензії. Вочевидь, за найгіршого сценарію,
на таких людей держава теж розраховує.